I'll just tell you this it's an acid
trip when we wrote it and I think in
order to really tell the story properly
you have to start with the fall of the
Angels right yeah which is you're in
another place you're in another realm
you know you need to go to hell you need
to go to sh so you're going to have hell
you're going to have Satan all that yeah
whoa sure you got to yeah right you got
to have his origin how do you rep how do
you depict
that this is a good
question so you've probably seen Mel
Gibson making headlines recently he's
been talking about remaking well not
remaking but making another film related
to one that he did along time ago so did
any of you see Passion of the Christ saw
when I was like 12 years ago could not
finish it it was too much I was probably
12 too like I was it was a while ago
made a big deal because it's like rated
R yeah Christian it's a bit too
realistic so is the the new one a
continuation of the that's a good
question so I was looking at this the
other day and then um coming soon and
other places like Screen Rant had
articles about this and they were
talking about um the film and so in his
words when he was interviewed about it
this is is what he said he said I'm
hoping next year sometime there's a lot
required because it's an acid trip
interesting he said my brother and I
Randall all sort of congregated on this
so there's some good heads put together
but there's some crazy stuff okay what
kind of crazy stuff is he talking about
and I think in order to really tell the
story properly you have to really start
with the fall of the
Angels which means you're in another
Place mhm you're in another realm you
need to go to
hell okay wow which to me sounds like
two different things when I'm thinking
about the
Bible but let's talk about this first
one a little bit let's talk about this
idea of the fall of the Angels yeah like
when does it mean it would be a prequal
to the crucifixion you know when when
the interview clips and stuff that I saw
he was kind kind of saying well to tell
this story which Passion of the Christ
to is supposed to be about the
resurrection okay but he says to tell
that story
properly he said it's not linear you
have to tell more surrounding story in
order to tell that story so they're
going to start with the war in heaven
maybe maybe I mean it it kind of sounds
like that but it kind of all of that
that he just said kind of ran together
and so it's hard for me to know I'm I'm
not him I'm not in his head so I don't
know yeah but at least from our
perspective that sounded like two
different ideas so let's start with the
first one where do we get this idea that
there are Fallen Angels Revelation talks
about it like the verse you have on the
go ahead read it and war broke out in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon and the dragon and his
angels fought but they did not Prevail
nor was there a place found for them in
heaven any longer so the Great Dragon
was cast out that Serpent of old called
the devil and Satan who deceives the
whole world he was cast out to the Earth
and his angels were cast out with him
yeah so then the question is
why right there was war in heaven why
Ezekiel 28 and Isaiah 14 give us the
answer to that I don't know if you're
going to go to that go ahead what what
were are you going to I'll just
paraphrase here and people can read it
for themselves at home but um those two
chapters talk about Satan you know and
and so this it says he was Fallen he was
kicked out of heaven and those two
chapters are like what happened before
that was the cause of it well he became
proud in his heart he said I want to be
like the most high I want to be like God
and and God's like yeah that's you're
sinning you're the cause of sin you the
reason why there all this destructions
happening and the reason for this war as
this explained in Revelation 12 that's
what those two chapters talk about yeah
and I think there's a couple of internal
clues in this chapter when you look at
it in in chapter 12 when we're reading
here it says in verse 9 so the Great
Dragon was cast out that Serpent of old
called the devil and Satan and he does
something he deceives people about what
about who God really is I think if you
if you kind of take a step back he's
he's misrepresenting the character of
God that's why Jesus had to come down
because our understanding of who God was
and that he was loving was in called
into question yeah so although this was
written in the last book of the Bible
you can see what he this this happened
like before even the the the events of
the first book of the Bible yeah right
and when he deceives did God really say
this is God really someone you can trust
the other internal clue I think we have
in that same chapter is when you go
towards the end of the chapter so it's
it's deceiving right and then it goes
and talks about all this stuff in the
chapter you get to the end of chapter 12
it becomes very clear it says and the
dragon was enraged with the woman and he
went out to make war with the rest of
her Offspring so he starts war in heaven
okay doesn't doesn't say exactly why it
just says he's going to deceive people
and then we get more clues he says and
he went to make war with the rest of her
Offspring so you have the woman which we
know in in Bible prophecy a woman is is
a church so that is has her
Offspring who keep the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ so in other words this contention
is they're doing something these people
are doing something and that's the
reason the dragon is coming after them
they're keeping the Commandments of God
and church testimony of Jesus Christ and
that's the reason for the Wrath Satan
was trying to reform the government of
God saying that it needed to be changed
don't care about the law it needs to be
different or whatever his arguments were
that were laid out and and then he
convinced the other angels that you know
you're holy and you don't need that yeah
and also speaking of the law um um sin
is the transgression of the law
according to the Bible so sin originated
in heaven well what happened how did Sin
start sin is the transgression of the
law he went against the law yeah we see
the beginning of that those those Clues
also in the Garden of Eden when um Satan
is tempting the human race to go against
God's word right you know did God really
say that is that what he meant and of
course what you're saying that results
in death because the wages of sin is
death is death always has been right so
big big perspective if you've you've
never heard that we have other videos
about this which we can reference in in
the comments below but that's that's one
part of at least what I think he's
talking about
um there was this other part though that
was referenced and I'm going to have one
of you two read this next verse for
Christ also suffered once for sins the
just for the unjust that he might bring
us to God being put to death in the
flesh but Made Alive by the spirit who
formerly were disobedient when Once the
Divine longsuffering waited in the days
of Noah while the ark was being prepared
in which a few that is eight Souls were
saved through Water by whom also he went
and preached to the spirits in
prisons no Gibson was likely referring
to this passage when he said we got to
go to hell yeah because there is a a
common um Evangelical Protestant
teaching that says when Jesus
died his Spirit or his soul his soul
Spirit yeah however they're defining it
went
to hell and then if you look at what new
testament scholarship says they said
well hell is not a good English
translation of what's going on it's it's
you know when it's talking about Hades
they're saying it's more akin to shol
and that he is going although there's
various opinions about this but they're
saying majority are saying he went to
this uh place where Christians who had
died
um who are going to go to heaven were
being held
temporarily and to preach to them like
declare good news declare Victory uh and
then
afterwards bring them to Heaven that I I
guess a logical thing that I would have
a problem with with just logically
thinking through this if you're going to
go to heaven why are you getting dropped
off at Hell first that's that's a
Catholic teaching
otherwise by insinuating that are you
saying that that you can go to hell but
then you can change your mind from hell
oh I don't like this place and so I'm
going to listen like what's what's where
where does this play
out yeah this is just the common this is
a common Protestant understanding that
before Jesus died people were not
allowed entrance into heaven they were
in a temp temporary holding place and
they were burning for the saved no they
were just there they were just
there and so this is but anyway not to
get lost in the details on that
particular but when we read the Bible
there I'm I'm I'm with you I think
there's some confusion that arises
because here uh clearly Jesus
died and multiple times in the Bible
even Jesus out of his own mouth um
referred to death as asleep yeah he said
it to Lazarus said it to Lazarus he said
one verse says he is dead and Jesus says
Lazarus is asleep and I want I go that I
may wake him up exactly um and then in
first Thessalonians 4 starting in verse
13 I'll read this passage real quick
this is the most sound verse I think or
easy to understand verse but what's
happening right because many people say
well that's that's not true Soul sleep
is not accurate it's not biblical it
really is but I do not want you to be
ignorant Brethren concerning those who
have fallen asleep lest you sorrow as
others who have no hope for if we
believe that Jesus died and rose again
even so God will bring with him those
who sleep in Jesus for this we say to
you by the word of the Lord that we who
are alive and remain until the coming of
the Lord will by no means precede those
who are asleep meaning you do not go to
heaven before those who are asleep in
Jesus meaning they're dead you are not
going to heaven first you actually this
is what happens for the Lord himself
will descend from heaven with a shout
with the voice of an archangel and with
the trumpet of God and the dead in
Christ will rise first they were Cur
first called asleep and now they called
the dead in Christ then we who are alive
and remain meaning those who are alive
when the second coming happens shall be
caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air and
thus we shall always be with the Lord
therefore Comfort one another with these
words so again like you're saying they
asleep if we die today it's like asleep
we close our eyes and boom we are awake
and there's many many more verses in the
Bible that indicate that idea and if you
believe that you know you're going to
heaven after Jesus died and was
resurrected right then he's calling
these two groups together the dead in
Christ and the ones that are alive at
the time together they're meeting
together in the clouds well you didn't
come from heaven and then go back down
to your body and then go back in so I I
think you just you can kind of logically
read a couple of those verses and be
like yeah that doesn't make sense that
they're in hell yeah and and you know
hell the idea of one eternal hell and I
know this is very controversial because
a lot of people believe this the idea of
eternal hell is not biblical I know
there's verses that talk about use the
words Eternal and all these kind of
things but you have to understand those
verses from a Hebrew mindset and how
they understood the concepts of Eternity
and what it was referencing to
um and also the concept of some dark pit
inside the middle of the Earth with fire
boiling and the Satan's there with the
pitch workor that's from paganism it's
Pagan beliefs that unfortunately crept
down into the the church into the Roman
Catholic church because and I mean this
very respectfully but the Roman Catholic
Church's teachings there was a lot of
paganism that got mixed with
Christianity that it swept down and then
eventually it just it just got into the
protestantism even though the
Reformation was happening and the
reformers such as Martin Luther and
zwingley and all those people were
trying to step away from those teachings
there were still some that remained and
these are some of them Eternal Hellfire
there's a pit in Hell a pit in the earth
that's burning and and we have a soul
even that is Pagan so you know that that
may be new ideas we can include some
links to some other videos where we
flesh this out more I mean obviously
we're we're not covering this topic
exhaustively here today yeah but in the
description we'll we'll put them all in
there that explain it yeah um you know
when we're talking about this we you go
back to the text if if Jesus is in the
grave and he was dead you know and this
is where my my logical mind has a hard
time with this and I know not everything
can be explained necessarily logically
but you know to me dead is dead it
doesn't mean dead and alive at the same
time or part of you alive and part of
you dead like dead is dead otherwise it
has no meaning um but if Jesus is dead
then what is this text talking about
when it says the spirit went and
preached to those that were in
prison the simplest way that I can um
look at this is when we look at another
text that references that event so would
you read this one from Genesis 6 yeah
and the Lord said my spirit shall not
strive with man forever for he is indeed
flesh yet his days shall be 120 years I
find it interesting that there are
commentaries that that when we're
referencing 1 Peter
38-20 uh they will indicate that the
spirit that's mentioned there the Greek
word is just the same word that used for
Spirit for wind it can mean either a a
spirit like something you would think of
as being disembodied or it can mean a
person and if it means a person then
that that that um spirits that are in
prison are just people
enslaved by sin and it gives a it gives
a use case it talks about the days of
Noah it says by whom he also went and
preached to the spirits in prison so
those who were you know people who were
alive who formerly were disobedient when
Once the Divine longsuffering waited in
the days of Noah so it's giving this use
case of how the spirit ministered yeah
the holy spirit
ministered in the times time of Noah to
when it says the spirits and prison
meaning to the people who were alive
then but who were disobedient and that's
exactly what this text is getting at
here in Genesis because God says my
spirit will not strive with man and not
forever in other words it is striving
with man now well how is it striving
with man through the preaching of Noah
right and the conviction of the the the
Consciousness right we have um it's John
um I want to say 16 that says the Spirit
uh when he comes uh he will guide you
into all truth and it says he will
convict the world of sin of
righteousness and the judgment to come
it's exactly what's happening here in
Noah's day yep convicting the world of
sin convicting the world of
righteousness right because these are
two opposite things there's sin and
there's
righteousness and the outcome of both of
those God is going to make a decision
between those two things and that's
called the judgment to come MH right so
that's what we see here and that's what
makes a whole lot of sense out of that
text and you can harmonize it with the
whole rest of the Bible um quite easily
so that's what's going on it's it's
almost like that that um you know sort
of Lost in Translation because of the
the punctuation like you know
when Jesus the thief on the cross Jesus
tells him you know today yeah I I tell
you today that that you'll be in the
Kingdom of Heaven that doesn't mean like
like today because if Jesus wasn't in
heaven you know he's in the grave then
today wouldn't make any sense no but
that punctuation that you put in there
is kind of throwing you off and in this
and it didn't exist before we didn't
have punctuation in the original Bible
translation so I think what's Happening
Here is like Jesus is talking about his
Spirit meaning the Holy Spirit
ministering to people but the way that
it reads right there is it's almost like
yeah Jesus is soul you know what I mean
yeah and and and that's not I think how
it was actually intended well you have a
you have another problem just speaking
of those two events if you put these
together if Jesus is dead and then he
goes to be in Paradise with the thief
how is he also
simultaneously yeah that's what I was
getting at or some or the place of the
you know I guess the way I when I read
some commentaries on this about other
people believe the way they're looking
at it is this is they say the thief
being saved I guess would have gone to
shol First the holding place and then
Jesus would go there and preach to them
good news yeah CU that's where he's
supposed to be going and then they all
go but the thing is like there's nowhere
in the Bible where it says oh by the way
there's a holding place there's it's not
found anywhere you can't you can't take
a can't take a verse like that and then
add in a bunch of like well this is how
I'm explaining it you have to let the
Bible explain it yeah I'm just I'm just
saying that's that's how it's understood
and I think real real quick the other
concept that that people would have a
problem with this well when Jesus has
had a disembodied Spirit or had a soul
that's what they would probably write
but that's not the case and I encourage
anybody in in who watching this video
who's like no that Jesus had a soul
please watch the videos that we're
putting in the description please watch
it because we we don't want to present
you with information and and then not
giving opportunity to check it out for
yourself so the only way we can come to
truth is if somebody tells you something
you've never heard of before or even
disagree with go check it out check it
out for yourself study for yourself so
check the links in the description
because there's tons of videos we've
made that explain the pagan origins of
the soul and how what the Bible says a
soul is so basically just you know kind
of recap I me we had our our main point
Jesus was dead in the grave other point
the spirit was preaching in Noah's day
and you know the spirit is still
preaching today it's still working on
the hearts and minds of men and the
judgment is coming um we are living in a
time of judgment God is coming soon
Jesus is coming soon and when he comes
your case is going to be decided uh
prior to that and so you want to be in a
right standing with God before he comes
to be able to meet him you know and so
he's looking at the hearts of men and
saying are they sinful or are they are
they righteous yep and there's only one
way we can be righteous and that's
through Christ so we want people to be
righteous we want them to be ready so
make sure that you are ready and another
uh thought about this is be careful with
the movies that you watch because I mean
you know he's putting out a movie that
is supposedly portraying the story of
Jesus but is it biblically accurate well
yeah I'm glad you said that pictures are
worth a thousand words so you know a lot
of times some of these things get seared
into our brain it's our brain's
recording all this stuff and and
Visually showing that I'm sure is going
to have an effect on a lot of people
yeah and I want to tell the viewers at
home we got a documentary on the chosen
I'm telling you I love the chosen I
watched the first three seasons
but then when I start working here and I
finally watched the documentary that
little I put out before I start working
here I watched it fighting against it
and then I got convicted and I stopped
watching it and I hope that you'll watch
it for yourself and come up uh make make
the decision for yourself well thank you
for that rousing discussion and for
those of you that are watching we hope
and pray that you will give this video a
like a thumbs up and that you'll make a
comment you may not agree with us that's
okay we uh we hope that you'll dialogue
with us and tell us uh why you don't
agree that's okay we we like dialogue we
like interacting and engaging with
people and a lot of times we're able to
answer those so make sure you do that
also uh if you want to help support this
work you can go to
ls. or you can help us by uh purchasing
some merch we have a company called
lightwear that we started and uh it has
these pretty cool t-shirts at least we
think they're pretty cool or hoodies
that you can purchase at lightwear and
where your witness so thank you so much
for watching thank you for joining us
and we'll catch you next time
[Music]